live from the theater where tonight CBS
News Democratic presidential debate will
be held in Charleston South Carolina
tonight we are just hours away from what
is shaping up to be another fiery
showdown here to help us get ready for
the big night
our CBS News political political
contributor Zed's Terry Sullivan and
Robbie look they know a thing or two
about presidential debates these two
look as you know was Hillary Clinton's
2016 campaign manager and Sullivan
managed Senator Marco Rubio's 2016
presidential campaign he also has a long
resume right here in South Carolina
politics so I'm really glad that you
guys are here because they tell me this
is a really big deal who do you think
has who has most at stake tonight there
are so many story lines between Bernie
Sanders Joe Biden Mike Bloomberg who has
the most who who was the most at stake
this evening Robbie start us off yeah
the Biden has to do well in South
Carolina later this week and so I think
for him slipping here yeah it's been
tightening up that always happens but
look this debate is you look for moments
when you can change things up this is a
moment for him to do it
Bloomberg has a lot because last time
didn't go so well so it's really
incumbent on him to do well this time
but I think overall this week Biden has
the most at stake you see that - yeah
berg not going so well is like Miss
Lincoln other than that how was the play
I mean like it did not go well yeah but
but like look this is Bernie this is
Bernie's to lose he just has to run the
clock out at this point in time when you
look at this he's leading in all the
Super Tuesday states except for Alabama
every single Super Tuesday state he is
got a solid lead and it's three days
away
after the South Carolina primary so this
is Bernie so you're right Biden
absolutely as the Moose to lose but I
don't know how he turns around what do
you mean well I mean they're still very
early in this campaign I find it so
interesting when they say Sanders surge
make-or-break where this is still very
early in the process is it no it's no
it's an important point you're making
where we've less than four percent of
the delegates however here's the thing
we're over 40 percent of the delegates
allocated after Super Tuesday by the end
of March
two thirds this moves so fast and Terry
makes a really important point you have
South Carolina on Saturday Super Tuesday
that next Tuesday it's just a few days
so again for Biden he's got to change up
the game what where Bernie really stands
to gain is I think Bloomberg put out a
memo they were anticipating he gets 30%
of the vote 45% of the delegates I don't
know if that's exactly right but Bernie
will get proportionately more delegates
than his vote because remember
candidates who don't get 15% they get
nothing so those delegates go to people
who are viable like burning zoo point
out Terry you said it didn't go well for
Mike Bloomberg he himself admitted it
was not his finest hour what does he
need to do tonight yeah I don't know
like I feel like make a difference if he
comes out tonight and he has success I
mean he has to survive okay that's
important like he just needs to emerge
somewhat unscathed but at the end of the
day I go back to this is Bernie's to
lose the the like debates are all about
four candidates how I raked them is how
they leave versus how they come in and
leave versus how they came in like that
and so Bernie Sanders who's coming in as
the clear front-runner and so if he just
leaves to say what he came in he's great
he's good yeah look there's one rule of
debase always for every can it always be
on offense
so for Bloomberg for Biden be on offense
take Bernie on for Bernie be on offense
take Bloomberg on take Biden on right so
that's that's what you're gonna see here
is that contest of who's who's actually
on offense and who's on D but at the
same time like it has to be like they
have to take Bernie on like the heck
with Bloomberg or anybody else there's
one guy who's in first place and it's
not Mike Bloomberg and so they need to
realize we need to engage engage Bernie
Sanders all right we'll be watching I'll
be right here saying Terry Sullivan
let's go back now to Anthony and Tony in
New York you'll be will be watching Gail
you'll be moderating
that really partner home for me four
percent of the delegates are in right
now if you were thinking like what is
this debate matter only a four percent
of the delegates in right now by the end
of March it'll be more than two-thirds
yeah Super Tuesday coming up s